[Music]
i have climbed
the highest mountains
i have run
through the fields
only to be
with you
only to be with you
but i still
haven't found
what i'm looking for
but i still
haven't found
what i'm looking for
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
dream big trees
we just got to be brave now wrong again
again
you will never be great johnny
what i'm looking for
[Applause]
found
what i'm looking for
do you want from me what do you want
from me what are you wondering why do
you know
why are you scared
[Applause]
hi my name is
[Applause]
stop i need big shows big ideas hey i
have a big one with click hello oh you
know calloway clay callaway is a recluse
no one's seen it for 15 years i'll give
you three weeks to get this show up and
running i won't let you down sir better
not or i'll throw you off the roof
there's nothing holding me back
i have dreamt of performing in red shore
city since i was a little kid
there's nothing holding me back this is
this is my daughter portia she wants to
meet galloway big fan my sister is on
her way to meet him right now
[Music]
if you could just give me some dance
lessons you will be saving my life how
do i know that you're not a weirdo how
do i know that you're
[Music]
legit when you go crazy
and here she is
the star of our show
rosita oh my gosh can i try no no no no
she's afraid she'll never be able to
play the part maybe this is for the best
i'll write you another party
there he is
clay calloway go away
don't you miss the music you just need
to play again no i can't i haven't even
heard one of my songs in over 15 years
and for good reason
i have climbed
the highest mountains
i have run
through the field it's okay
your songs will carry
[Music]
dream big dreams
that's what i always said right
[Music]
there's always a choice
just never have the guts to make the
right one
activating piggy power
[Music]
so
[Music]